foreign now for most of us living out
one dream would be satisfying enough but
that is not the case for likolani
Arthurs when nikolani had to retire as a
professional ballerina that's stream
number one she pursued another
challenging career dream number two in
an entirely different field CBS News
correspondent Michael George has the
story of this ballet dancer's second
calling
as a little girl likolani Arthurs had
Big Dreams of performing on stage as a
ballerina the stage gets dark and it's
just you with a spotlight and it feels
like you're dancing for yourself the
native Hawaiian dedicated her life to
dance even patching up a future in the
Ivy Leagues to start her ballet career
in New York hold on you turned down
Harvard not a lot of people turned down
Harvard I did it was a very difficult
decision but I really knew that like I
had this once in a lifetime opportunity
to dance with the New York City Ballet
and she made it to one of ballet's
biggest stages performing alongside some
of the best dancers in the world it was
a dream come true I mean that was like
the one thing I was hoping for you know
it was a dream of like a young girl
but the ballet life doesn't last forever
due to its demanding physical toll
Arthurs knew she'd need a new career
that's when she at the age of 30 decided
she was going to trade her ballet
slippers for scrubs and become a doctor
that seems like a huge leap did it feel
that way to you I like to think that if
you're doing something that you love
sort of doors will open up for you
valet and surgery may seem a world apart
but listen to the way Arthurs describes
a kidney transplant it was one of the
most elegant things I had seen it was
Art you could say I think of ballet as
elegant you see that in surgery exactly
I see a lot of Art and creativity in
surgery Arthur says 15 years worth of
physical wear and tear helped her gain a
better understanding of the human body
as a dancer you're very preoccupied with
how the body works and how to make it
work to the best of its ability I was
always fascinated with Anatomy she
enrolled in medical school at NYU all
while starting a family of her own her
decision to focus on surgery came after
watching her father's struggle with lung
cancer it was awful I mean just
absolutely terrible we lost him two days
before my second year of medical school
started and six weeks after I gave birth
to my first son is your dad the reason
you became a doctor
definitely the reason I'm going to be a
surgeon I felt like with a surgeon's
help sooner things might have been
different for him can you maybe show me
how to run the battle from the like the
stomach and last summer really important
for any surgeon to know Arthur started
her surgical residency at NYU langone
what does it sound like to hear that Dr
Arthur's it sounds extremely foreign the
first day I had to say Dr Arthur's it
was exciting but also it definitely you
know you have a new a new responsibility
do you have any advice for people who
would want to make this drastic career
change in their lives you won't know if
you can do it until you do it if you
feel like it's something you're
passionate about and you want to do it
you know make the leap it won't be quite
as hard as it might seem
now I asked Dr Arthurs does she ever
Miss dancing she said that she does but
she also told me when she's holding a
patient's hand and comforting them right
before surgery she says that's a feeling
that she never got in her old career she
knows she made the right choice wow good
story how'd you find out about it
she's just somebody that's been talked
about in the hospital circles because
it's so incredible to see that
transformation but she hasn't really
gotten a lot of attention for and so
when I heard about her I just thought
we've all had that thought of switching
careers yeah here's somebody who
actually took that leap right yeah
that's the plan you have to have we were
talking about it to be a ballerina and
then the discipline you you would have
to have to study medicine they just go
here I have so much respect for doctors
in general I cannot I don't like the the
I can never be a doctor or a surgeon the
insides of the human body is not for me
Psychiatry yeah thank you thank you for
me or being one I'm not sure maybe both
talk about it okay